vaincu lyon sur ce plateau un comédien
de cinéma comédien de théâtre qui nous
fait rire parfois qui nous émeut andré
wilms bonjour bonjour ça va bien ouais
pour l'instant car oui ça va moins bien
après mais enfin pour l'instant
s'avéreront je vous poserai la question
de 26 minutes d'accord
grosse grosse actu d'abord on va parler
de berlin vous étiez ce week-end vous
êtes arrivé ce matin à strasbourg qu'est
ce qui s'est passé là-bas le dernier
film d'aki kaurismaki le dernier film
muet du 20e siècle avec un orchestre
film muet présenté au dernier d'un film
festival film muet et oui et quand on
joue dans un film muet quand un comédien
et un vieil habitué à parler comment
comment ça se passe c'est bien ça rappe
ça repose quoi et puis pour toute
l'économie que j'ai dit c'est bien ça
merci unis enfin il souhaite enfin c'est
vrai qu'actuellement ça doit être dur de
jouer dans ces magnifiques même temps
parce qu'il ya que les yeux qui doivent
parler et plus le reste est pire on
parle beaucoup en ce moment tout le
monde parle énormément il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de beaux de flot de paroles
c'est magnifique de voir un truc qui
calme une fois où il n'y a pas tellement
de bordel quoi tout le monde parle pas
sans arrêt quoi c'est vraiment agréable
ayant la congrégation 36 richard iii bad
boy vous allez jouer en vacances et
avant que je me sois je suis habitué ça
je connais aurait on connaissait les
autres imprécations 5,6 une adaptation
de shakespeare très très actuelle la
richard iii c'est un tel qu'un monstre
en fait que voilà un carnet on m'a dit
tu fermes et donc j'ai un slogan
invitation de richard iii et d albi même
les bêtes éprouve de la pitié et lui dit
moi je ne les provoque une donc je ne
suis pas une bête mais on a tout le
temps là vous pouvez faire pas besoin
des slogans ça c'est à peu près de
slogans de richard iii quoi dirigée par
michel c c'est une vieille amitié ah
ouais rien mon argent n'est obligé
d'être fidèle quoi
comprendrez pourquoi matin
en ville c'est la ville de bonjour juste
avant cela tient je voulais vous dire
que yvan muller avait gagné le trophée
andros on l'a reçu il ya un mois on lui
avait souhaité bonne chance toute
l'équipe de bonjour et bien l'alsacien a
gagné pour la quatrième fois consécutive
donc voila c'était un petit clin d'oeil
il a gagné avec panache et le pilote du
trophée andros vous suivez ça un petit
peu le sport
si j'ai vu hier soir un match à canal+
marseille ouais
contre chez paulo ap toulouse marseille
toulouse et c'était magnifique comme
d'habitude maurice [ __ ] en plus c'est
toujours race la race humaine allez on
va les rendre le portrait de jean ferrat
[Musique]
andré wilms nous avons essayé de
remonter le temps à la recherche de vos
premiers souvenirs vos premières
tentatives de comédiens alors j'aimerais
savoir si ce dessin là vous dit quelque
chose regarder ça vous rappelle des
souvenirs j'atteins teint ou quoi voilà
c'est un tintin au congo voilà alors il
faut savoir que quand il avait 6 ans et
bien toute sa famille était bay par ses
talents parce qu'il avait un vrai chic
pour mettre des histoires en musique et
il paraît que sur tintin au congo vous
vous baladiez avec un petit tambour à
clapiers dessus tout fier je me souviens
encore de la chanson où elle est où lé
maliba malawi
alors dans sa famille la fibre
artistique se résumait au piano puisque
sa maman et sa tata faisait du piano et
lui il avait un vrai don pour la musique
alors il aurait pu devenir musicien
également le problème c'est que
l'apprentissage était très très
rigoureux c'était très strictes pas
beaucoup de place pour la créativité et
donc dans ce cas dans un cadre strict et
bien il n'aurait pas vraiment été
capable de s'épanouir scolarité
scolarité ça l'intérêt semble avoir sur
mesure voilà donc
ces études relativement jeune pour
devenir peintre en bâtiment puis ensuite
machine aux comédiens et depuis vingt
gravitent dans le milieu du théâtre dont
comédiens metteurs en scène ou alors
acteur au cinéma alors s'il fallait
faire une esquisse de son caractère vous
prenez le personnage qu'il incarne dans
le film la vie est un long fleuve
tranquille un don vous voyez le père de
famille le quesnoy un peu tiers ordre un
peu coincé et bien lui c'est tout
l'inversé en fait si des dates d'un
style plutôt on va dire anarchique ou
provocateur il n'aime pas
particulièrement l'ordre établi ce qui
explique que déjà l'adolescence il a
refusé de faire son service militaire ce
qui doivent vivre des trucs comme ça la
télévision ce qui les avait dit de vivre
chez soi s'énervait contre moi
puisqu'à l'époque on mettait les gens en
prison pour ça et d'ailleurs il a
horreur ça ne va pas arranger votre cas
de tout ce qui est rattachée au côté
bourgeois la classe bourgeoise en
général ils exècrent ce qui m'amène
d'ailleurs imposé une question je me dis
que vous devez vivre un véritable
calvaire au quotidien puisqu'il faut
savoir que ce monsieur habite le xviième
à paris dieu mort dans une rue privée
avec des villas des jardins vous y force
aux yeux non alors que sa propriétaire
d'abord une localité qui a dit je ne
possède rien j'ai même pas de voiture et
comme bons jeux repas pas que les
voisins ça mais sur les voisins c'est la
directrice du ballet de l'opéra de paris
puis l'autre chez un régisseur ça va
encore à quoi ça va encore en tout cas
c'est vrai que dans cette ville avec
jardin il paraît que le jardin ben ils
poussent ce qu'il veut c'est pas du tout
enfin bon c'est pas du tout aimé que tu
n'es pas seule mais ça n'intéresse
strictement personne
terminons termine quand même pour savoir
ce que fait andré wilms quand il ne fait
pas de théâtre avait fait plein de
choses mille passion qui sont à mille
lieues des planches par exemple il est
capable de chercher des champignons
pendant cinq heures d'affilée je ne
m'intéresse presque plus sculpteur tu
vois la ramasse et les crabes aussi un
ck oui je sais très bien faire la soupe
aux est riche mais je pourrais pas le
dire les recettes en alsacien
les randonnées mes parents donner une
heure au bois de vincennes à randonner
10 heures de marche oui ça je me baigne
ou alors le plus surprenant notamment
par rapport à ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure maurice [ __ ] me semble-t-il
pour reprendre vos paroles c'est le foot
le foot et il a d'ailleurs lui-même joué
au racing club de strasbourg chez les
cadettes j'ai honte de ça mais je suis
passionné vous dans les stades qu'est-ce
que vous criez ou devant la télé ça je
me souviens de lui très belle anecdote
parce que à l'époque il y avait un jour
black qui s'appelait dans notre équipe
toko oui et dans l'équipe d'en face je
sais plus laquelle il y en avait une un
autre noir donc quand l'outrenoir
l'équipe d'en face toucher le ballon on
entend des gens dire également en écoute
je l'aï fait sans me casser le cul et le
[ __ ] cacao a été quand le nôtre toucher
la balle aux la perle noire
les félins comme dans sa race et même
même moment c'est un peu pareil ici en
fait
ça c'est qu'en fait quand régis fait une
bonne chronique tout se passe bien et
après avoir parlé un petit peu de ce que
vous avez fait un film qui a été un gros
succès là la vie est un long fleuve
tranquille moment comment ça c'est fait
le casting parce qu'on va vous voir ses
personnages très catho très droit rigide
qui vous voit son épouse c'est à dire
qu'à l'epoque chatiliez trouvait pas
l'acteur
mais on lui avait présentée tous ceux
qui traditionnellement joue les bourges
dans le cinéma français mais à l'époque
où j'étais très mal rasé déjà les
cheveux très longs on m'a présenté à lui
et moi je crois que c'était pour mes
cheveux groseille c'est-à-dire pour
l'autre
et puis je sais paille nous regarder
sans arrêt comme ça d'un oeil bizarre et
un moment donné me connaissant il m'a
dit je t'en supplie rendrait ce que tu
voudrais te couper les cheveux j'veux du
beau après tout pourquoi poche comme
bien là présent que je me coupe les
cheveux donc il a dit massa sera toi
monsieur le quesnoy j'ai été malade
alors j'ai pris comme modèle les mecs
qui prennent des airs inter quoi ici
tous les matins ouais on le voit c'est
exactement cela quoi je les ai
simplement regarder pendant une semaine
j'ai compris que j'allais m'acheter mon
costume avec une costumière très doué
par exemple le simple fait de repasser
les jeans on n'a plus rien à jouer quoi
oui c'est ça va pas non voilà andré
villageois quoi on va vous voir
justement très vite dans le rôle de
monsieur le quesnoy comme mon dieu
[Musique]
oui voyez pas nécessaire
merci les enfants
bravo mon fils je fait d'énormes progrès
vous savez pierre a mis les bouchées
doubles pour être prêt aujourd'hui un
jour sera un grand piano célèbre voilà
bien notre bernadette comme tu vas vite
en besogne mais c'est déjà formidable
voilà papa votre cadeau
est-ce que c'est
aux agenais de sauvetage pour le 420 m
bonne idée oui il me semblait bien vous
avez perdu votre l'été dernier à la
régate du 15 août au parc mauvais
souvenir ce soir d'ailleurs celui là est
beaucoup mieux
au
téléphone il est très
content
à l'eau
non
oh mon dieu
anniversaires gâcher puisqu'il ya un
enterrement le lendemain vous avez l'air
la mine est là en vous voyant et parce
que ces trucs me courent eux le haricot
mais c'est vrai que chaque fois que vous
diffusez saffré des gens dans la rue ils
me disent c'est lundi c'est ravioli oh
oui
déjà une entente
5556 ai marre de vous ramener des
raviolis fait partie des rôles qui ont
marqué quand même votre carrière
ouais ouais mais après j'ai tout de
suite dû arrêter parce que j'étais parti
pour en faire cinq cent cinquante comme
ça le bourgeois coincé avec un balai
dans le cul j'étais parti quoi je fais
un virage
ça va on fait une fois mais pas deux
canadairs et deux continue ouais c'est
bien une fois je me suis beaucoup amusé
d'abord on vous voit j'ai tous vos 10
nino ferrer
et laurent salvail a un côté nino ferrer
j'ai aussi toujours rêvé d'être chanteur
de variété j'ai raté on reparlera de
musique un petit peu ce que voudrait
attaques souvent je rajoute reste encore
sur un film qui m'a étonné je vous ai
cherché dans le générique des alsaciens
ou des 2 mathilde et vous n'y êtes pas
ah je ne veux pas faire de choses sur
l'alsace je veux pas être un comédien
régional enfin
bon voulez que je dise répondre
sérieusement ou complaisante annonce
fairisme bon c'est un sujet très délicat
et moi sur l'alsace c'est les malgré
nous des choses comme ça tout sujet là
et je trouve que c est très schématique
kg pas aimait beaucoup le scénario quand
je les lui bien que ce soit mon cobra
deutsch qui participé mais puisque gêné
de jouer des alsaciens ça m'énerve la
seule chose que j'aurais aimé faire
c'est jouer devant agde germain muller
rob a rappelé j'ai fait une fois un truc
avec lui ça ça m'a plu parce que c'était
un acteur énorme formidable
extraordinaire un grand acteur
shakespearien on en parle souvent d'un
bonjour ouais et là j'étais honoré de
travailler germain muller parce que
c'est les alsaciens n'ont all is
alsaciens bien je vais pas passer ma vie
à faire alsacien qua non mais c'est vrai
mais même dans les alsaciens ne voulait
pas être catalogué en fait
j'aime pas les tribus
mais vraiment pas maintenant il ya to
man et les bretons il ya l'image dans
les trucs des écossais dole
non ça m'énerve un peu ça met gentiment
gentiment vous écrivez non non non je ne
suis pas douée quoi j'ai tenté oui mais
je me suis vite aperçu qu'il valait
mieux que j'arrête vous on privilégie le
théâtre le cinéma horaire entre les
douces et la même approche la deuxième
question qu'on me pose souvent alors
donc je vais répondre politiquement
l'équipement non sérieux répond
sérieusement ce comme disait un second
tome
je suis devenu acteur parce que j'ai vu
rintintin de télévision est ce qu'un
train arrive à faire il ya aucune raison
que j arrive donc c'est toujours un peu
la réponse que je donne non très
sérieusement différence entre cinéma
étaient les bons quant au cinéma et télé
entre cinéma et théâtre
ouais faut moi jouer au cinéma quoi faut
- joulia vraiment les acteurs pour vous
et les comédiens je dis souvent l'écho
médaille c'est ce que disent oui sa
sauce hip hop comme c'est un peu snob ah
oui moi j'y comprends rien très
franchement
y'a qu'en france on fait cette
distinction la comédienne de théâtre et
comédien de cinéma en angleterre on l'a
fait en amérique on l'a fait parce que
même à jouer le roi lire ici en france
il ya une méfiance sur les comédiens de
théâtre parce que les metteurs en scène
soul is cool à la lazio il va me fait
chier comme il ya une différence entre
les comédiens qui font de la télévision
privée s'était coupé et surtout c'est la
réputation épouvantable dès qu'on pose
une question et tu roules half year ne
fait d'engager les intellos un peu de
masturbation notamment ils savaient ce
qu'ils jouent astérix d'âge aurait mieux
fait dans un je suis là quoi la vie et
aviez vous allez on va on va découvrir
un rôle en 95
c'est un vrai premier rôle le grand
blanc de l'an barème avec le rôle
d'albert schweitzer on en parle juste
après ce sujet de la rédaction de france
3 très étonnant
je ne veux une fois je ne vais pas le
voir deux
films anti chrétien anti français n'est
ce pas et entre européens n'est ce pas
non dit j'aurais dit rien il n'y a pas
que les dons mon cher politique il ya
mon travail mais écrit mes conférences
des concerts à travers le monde entier
et ensuite les tons qu'on fait c'est au
docteur schweitzer qu'on les fait erreur
docteur vous n'êtes rien sans les
malades ni les africains ici tout
appartient à l'afrique votre problème
docteur schweitzer n'a jamais été
l'émancipation de ce peuple vous avez
seulement voulu partager notre enfer en
espérant gagner le ciel
se nomme contradictoire c'est un homme
complexe c'est pas un homme simple pour
les uns c'est un [ __ ]
néocolonialistes pour les autres c'est
un sein et entre les deux on a essayé de
trouver une voie qui ne soit pas
réductrice semblerait que la voix qui
est pas réductrice sont encore plus
polémique que les oies réductrice le
rendez vous s'annonce et conviviale même
si leur regard du réalisateur
camerounais var secte boko bio sur
albert schweitzer n'avait pas l'air de
plaire aux autorités de kaysersberg on
était dans la fiction
il fallait tirer ce thé
non c'est pas seulement le cinéma il
faut pas en tirer seulement comme ça
lorsque la conversation a basculé dans
la réalité alsacienne le ton est monté
la rupture elle se retranche enel le
maire a claqué la porte quelques cheveux
qui n'est pas correct
il y avait beaucoup mais c'est pas à eux
j'ai pas les artistes qui va refaire les
lois chacun a ses idées et ses opinions
je trouve c'est lamentable de guerre a
fini dans ce genre sur l'homme qui a
certainement fait plus de bien que 2 du
mal dans la vie
même si la réalisation laisse beaucoup à
désirer ce film bouscule bien sûr le
grand mythe du bon docteur schweitzer à
kaysersberg on ne l'a pas accepté reste
au public à se faire sa propre opinion
[Musique]
film controversé du prêteur de 15 ans
merde on n'a pas tellement apprécié avec
du recul maintenant comment il était ce
personnage d'albert schweitzer comme je
dois je retiens rien de ce que j'ai dit
à l'époque c'était un personnage
contradictoire c'est-à-dire que c'était
à la fois pour l'époque un petit caïd
egypte et à des intuitions de génie et
c'était à la fois mais il faut le
resituer dans l'époque et c'était bien
ça le truc halal à l'époque on disait
les [ __ ] on lisait pas nos frères
d'afrique 1 de couleurs ou des choses on
prenait pas de précaution il était aussi
l'héritier de toute une tradition
coloniale française il était mégalomane
il s'est installé là où braz a posé pour
la première fois le pied c'est là qu'il
a dit je construirai ma mission et s'est
fait relooker parler les journalistes de
live c'est à dire c'est le premier cas
compris l'importance des médias par
exemple tout son look des cheveux blancs
la moustache douce et une journaliste de
life qui lui a fait quoi qui l'a relooké
pour être c'était le premier french
doctor il n'est pas aussi blancs que
l'image qu'il donnait de bons il
gueulait en alsacien chose on m'a
souvent dit c'est impossible dakic
automatisé dans le film est choisie a
écrit dans ses mémoires je jure en
alsacien parce que dieu ne le comprends
pas
il ya tout ça on avait quand même
documenté bon c'est le regard d'un noir
c'est un mais c'est un regard à mon avis
très bien sûr schweitzer bon le film
était un peu raté ça il faut se dire les
choses comme elles sont le film était un
peu une telle est améliorée
mais bon maintenant avec le recul
je sais que le maire de kaysersberg il a
sauté moi pas encore allé régis vous
allez nous donner quelques traductions
littérales de suite me reste deux trois
petites minutes on commence avec alors
si on commence on dit que ce n'est pas à
trappes ablakwa pensez vous ce n'est pas
par des chalets de force ça veut dire
c'est insaisissable c'est
incompréhensible comme ce que je dis
parfois je vais vous dire une autre
chose un aiguiseurs de couteaux ça vous
rappelle quoi
à charge les fortes c'est dû à charge ce
livre c'est un bâtard lorsqu'on parle
d'un chien en fait est un faux bonne éco
plate
sagement souvenait pas voilà les pardons
je me souviens ce qu'on disait sur les
puces boulevard jones ah bah voilà donc
là c'est très vivant et vivaces une
dernière petite chose absolument avoir
quelque chose au flotteur c'est à dire
être zinzin et si je vous dis que lionel
augier a des jambes x ça n'a rien à voir
avec les films du même nom mais c'est
qu'il a des jambes arquées tout
simplement j'ai parlé jean-marc j'en
serai à part dont on revient sur
imprécations 36 richard iii vous êtes en
pleine préparation le rôle de la
représentation c'est du 25 février au 20
mars qu'est ce qu'on peut dire alors sur
la force de ce personnage que vous
interprétez
c'est une promenade autour de richard
iii c'est plutôt looking for eric
charden c'est nous avec deuil sont là
toujours griffonné dans les marches du
théâtre denis olympique seul on n'est
pas dans la grande moi je vais j'aime
assez me promener sur les marges comme
ça dans un taux l'institution me reprend
mais moi j'aime bien mon nom mort est
évadé donc c'est notre griffonnages à
nous sur son richard iii bad boy c'est
parce que en ce moment il y avait plein
de trucs dont je voulais parler mais
qu'on peut pas donc je j invite tout le
monde à lire l'excellent article de
sollers dans le monde qui s'appelle la
france moisie ouais ouais parce qu'il
parle très très bien de ce qui se passe
pas bien en ce moment en france
notamment quand les chasseurs se met
t'agresser mon ami cohn bendit en le
traitant de [ __ ] et de [ __ ] d'enculés
le rouquin et ses appuis après monsieur
millon monsieur yan blomet ce chat est
désert mais si le pacs on a droit tous
abattent ou ça vous le retrouverez dans
l'imprécation
ah ouais voilà voilà une façon de parler
de la pierre voilà c'est comme ça plus
parce que prétend pas que le théâtre
peut changer la société c'est une forme
légère cabaret avec beaucoup de rock and
roll quoi tend justement ce rock n roll
vous êtes très sensible à la musique
grandi avec le rock mon idole c'était
johnny hallyday c'est pour ça que j'ai
accepté de faire un feuilleton avec plus
lamentable j'étais juste pour le voir
j'étais comme un petit garçon je vais le
droit de le toucher je tourne et six
mois avec lui j'étais content le groupe
qui accompagne imprécations c'est
sentimental bourreau ces quatre jeunes
musiciens à mon avis remarquable mais ça
on peut pas dire avant qu'on fasse le
spectacle parce qu'après on a toujours
l'air prétentieux puis tout va toujours
très bien dans le meilleur des mondes et
nous sommes une grande famille nous ne
sommes pas une bonne alors c'est donc à
voir à partir du 25 février jusqu'au 20
mars au théâtre national de strasbourg
le tms et ses mises en scène par votre
camarade michel deutsch merci grand
merci et longue pièce on se retrouve
demain avec les agréables je tiens le
débat c'est gentil
[Musique]